[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais
bonsoir à toutes et à tous et bienvenue
dans le set suite week end voici les
titres de ce vendredi 4 juin une
nouvelle étape a été franchie dans le
projet de zones à faibles émissions du
grand paris les véhicules portant des
vignettes critères 4 ne peuvent plus
circuler à l'intérieur de cette zone
depuis le 1er juin mais les yvelines
résistent nous ferons le point en sept
années 2000 21 ce sont les 100 ans de la
radio c'est en 1921 que la première
station commencé à émettre depuis la
tour eiffel à paris
cent ans plus tard les postes à galène
et sapeurs télégraphiste ne sont plus là
mais la radio 6 et avec elle ce qu'ils
ont façonné patrice carmouze directeur
de l'information de tv 78 nous racontera
à ses meilleurs souvenirs de sa carrière
en radio enfin côté loisirs cette
semaine avec célia gars tsongo nous vous
proposerons de découvrir une nouvelle
boutique de jeux de société à montigny
le bretonneux
mais aussi nous irons voir les 70
exposants de pari fermier à la ferme de
viltain à jouy en josas
et
depuis mardi 1er juin les véhicules
ayant des vignettes critères cad sont
interdits de circulation dans la zone à
faible émission délimité par l'a86 de la
métropole du grand paris une nouvelle
phase d'expansion qui ne fait pas
l'unanimité
les yvelines résiste reportage de ces
yaga 200 go et bérangère bourgois le
projet en cours c'est qu'on va changer
de voiture alors qu'elle a 84 1000 km ma
voiture
il ya des gens qui n'ont pas accès à des
véhicules propres donc mais qui doit
commander travail et la 86è totoro
définit le périmètre de la zone à faible
émission métropolitaine qui interdit
depuis mardi 1er juin la circulation des
véhicules critères 4 une nouvelle phase
d'extension puisque les véhicules
critères cinq étaient déjà non autorisée
depuis 2019
c'est une décision importante parce que
c'est un processus qui vise évidemment
améliorer le cadre de vie la santé
puisque airparif estime estima on verra
en france bilan de cette zone à faible
émission à un moment donné on veut
baisser de 6 et 8% des émissions oxydes
d azote est quasiment équivalent sur les
particules fines sur la zone en question
normalement la zdf comprend deux commune
yvelinoise qui entrent dans le périmètre
intérieur de l'a86 viroflay et vélizy
villacoublay
ces deux mairies ne veulent pas de cette
interdiction pour ses usagers on en
prend de détruire une bonne partie des
plus faibles revenus et de le pont pour
le plus long pour que l'on travaille et
on n'est pas des go ou ici on compte que
c'est une bonne mesure il faut faire
venir des véhicules polluants un avis
partagé par l'association 40 millions
d'automobilistes qui ne comprend pas
cette interdiction
vous avez des gens qui sont d'un côté
bas à 80 du mauvais côté de la a86 qui
ont leur médecin leur côté qu'ils ont
leur école de l'autre côté qui ont leur
commerce de l'autre côté ils pourront
plus aller chez leur médecin à l'école
ou à leur commerce
alors qu'est ce qu'ils vont faire on
prend leur voiture ils vont aller dans
un centre commercial à 20 ou 30 km à
l'extérieur
vous parlez d'une réduction de la
pollution donc tout ça a été mis en
place par des élites je pense que c'est
beaucoup plus politique
que efficace en termes de résultats pour
autant des aides seront mises en place
pour changer de véhicule jusqu'à dix
neuf mille euros pour un véhicule
électrique ou hybride 9 et jusqu'à 12000
euros dette pour un véhicule électrique
ou hybride d'occasions pour rappel les
véhicules avec vignette critères quatre
sont des voitures diesel immatriculés
avant le 1er janvier 2006 les deux roues
motorisés d'avant juillet 2004 sont
également conservés
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme je vous le disais en titre en
début de semaine nous fêtions les 100
ans de la radio pour en parler patrice
carmouze directeur de l'information de
tv sont dit bonsoir j'ai pas s'entendre
encore vous n'avez pas 50 ans je le sais
bien
bah on va prendre un petit peu
d'histoire du coup tout d'abord c'est en
1921 que la première station commencé à
émettre depuis la tour eiffel à paris
ces stations et mais d'abord des
bulletins météo et de la musique
cent ans plus tard les postes à galène
et les sapeurs télégraphique ne sont
plus là mais la radio si elle est bien
toujours là et avec elle ce qu'ils ont
façonné patrice carmouze vous avez
commencé votre carrière en radio
avant de vous diriger vers la télévision
vous avez commencé votre carrière à
france inter puis vous êtes passé par
europe 1 et vous avez même été rédacteur
en chef de l'émission à la bonne heure
de stéphane bern sur rtl
exactement mais je veux tout de stuff
box qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie de
faire de la radio justement assez
formidable la radio moi j'ai toujours
préféré même la radio à la télévision
parce que il ya un contact direct avec
avec des auditeurs on a une liberté
d'abord on peut arriver sur s'habiller
se maquiller on a c'est très simple à la
hadda télécom c'est comme l'image moi
j'ai toujours le souvenir d'une soirée
électorale vivait un homme politique qui
avait un pansement sur le nez le type tu
dis des choses absolument extraordinaire
très intelligente mais personne n'a
écouté tout le monde y est mais qui pour
quoi il a faussement souvenez vous ayez
tandis qu'à la radio on écoute on est là
on est dans le haut liens très forts
avec les auditeurs qui peuvent appeler
qui peuvent d'abord c'est très simple il
ya un téléphone on peut on peut
interagir très vite
donc tout ça fait que c'est un média
assez exceptionnel oui on est plus
concentré sur les changes finalement
n'est plus aussi dans l'intimité
peut-être dans l'intimité dans le fond
des choses si les choux et des gens
écoutent réagi ce jeudi aux télévisions
n'est plus normal on est c'est l'image
qui est qui qui qui domine donc c'est
pas tout à fait la même chose c'est même
assez différent et c'est ce qu'on aime
faire quand même la télévision cassure
mais on continue à parler de la radio à
l'occasion de ce centenaire de la radio
quel est votre meilleur souvenir
justement dans ce média qu'est la radio
ouh là là parce que j'avais fait
beaucoup donc tendue et je dirais 3
allée un perso alors c'était juste et à
bfm à l'époque j'étais anime une
émission qui s'appelait incarne aux
trois quarts culture s'est dit non et
tout le monde cherchait michel
houellebecq parce qu'il avait dit et des
chaussures là sur la religion sur
l'islam et l'islam et de la plus comme
des religions saluer valu d'être
poursuivi et tout ça donc ils se
montraient plus j'étais il était de
l'été le seul fait qu'il est il devenu
donc ça c'était c'était plutôt bien et
puis après il est des souvenirs un peu
en dehors même des émissions j'ai
toujours le souvenir d'une émission
qu'on avait fait à la montagne et alors
le soir on avait été dîner auront enfin
dans les hauteurs on était un rêve un
peu bu tout ça et j'ai aussi une
descente en luge avec france françois
mon rêve qui est resté dans des
souvenirs et puis il y avait aussi quand
on est l europe avec christophe on
partait parfois du studio de melun vont
s'absenter plus personne à l'antenne
c'était assez marrant
des souvenirs plein la tête mais pour
vous quel avenir de la radio justement
alors je crois que ça m'a beaucoup
frappé sa jeu quand j'étais notamment
avant les grandes stations
j'ai l'impression qu'ils aient pas
beaucoup de réflexion la part des
dirigeants de radios sur ce qu'est
l'avenir de la radio qui s'est d'abord
c'est un média qui aujourd'hui écouter
plus tout par ces personnes assez âgées
ça médias qui est en train d'évoluer il
ya de nouvelles façons de avec
indemnités il ya internet il ya le
podcast qui devient de plus en plus
fréquentes pendant très longtemps la
radio c'est l'immédiateté quoi il y
avait une info et ça a été très vrai
continue des grands événements en mai 68
c'était ça c'était la voc d'europe 1 et
de rtl c'est parce qu'ils étaient sur le
terrain etc la radio nationale était un
peu moins elle était plus figé donc il
était là les événements les grands
discours
quand quand de gaulle enfin fait son
appel le 18 juin c'est à la radio
évidemment mais mais quand il dissout
l'assemblée nationale en 68 cll ya une
crise une grande tente lui de fait la
radio y'a pas l'image et ses plus forts
historiquement donc c'était ça c'est
plus ça aujourd'hui évidemment il ya les
podcasts si elle fait que les gens
écoutent de deux tous les endroits du
monde et et alors
ya peut-être quelque chose à enfin sur
lequel il faudrait réfléchir
en effet un lien entre le monde entier
qui pourrait se faire grâce à la radio
je crois radio mondialisé et humour eh
bien merci patrice carmouze pour ces
précisions pour vos souvenirs en
espérant que le prochain centenaire de
la radio soit tout aussi bon et surtout
si vous voulez en savoir plus
on verra bien sûr si vous voulez en
savoir plus sur l'histoire de la radio
n'hésitez pas à retrouver l'émission le
club de la presse présentée par wilfrid
richy qui sera diffusé vendredi 4 juin à
20 heures
mais aussi sur notre site internet tv 78
points comme les médias locaux se
réunissent pour évoquer l'histoire de la
radio avec ce sens et dans le reste de
l'actualité
on passe justement au résumer
l'actualité de la semaine dans les
yvelines avec mélanie poquet l'injection
et depuis le 31 mai possible dès 18 ans
et son co morbidités la campagne de
vaccination contre la copie 19 s'est
élargi
objectif du gouvernement à atteindre les
30 millions de primo vacciner enjoindre
sensibiliser au respect de
l'environnement naturel aventure c'est
le rallye 100% féminin en voiture
électrique pour conduire de façon
économe trek et orientations le départ a
été donné devant la mairie de versailles
le 30 mai sensibiliser jusque dans les
foyers la ville de ben a conçu des sacs
à pain avec numéros d'urgence et
violente omettre les deux boulangeries
de la ville vont distribuer dix mille
sacs à leurs clients un mois après le
lancement un premier bilan sur
l'utilisation des trottinettes
électriques à saint quentin en yvelines
près de 2000 passé à beaune nord ont été
achetés 6000 trajets ont été réalisés
deux jours déco festival les élèves du
lycée 17 mar à mort par ont été
sensibilisés à divers pollution entre
friterie gratuite et expositions choc
[Musique]
et après une semaine bien chargée quoi
de mieux que de se détendre le week end
comme chaque semaine c'est les agat son
go vous propose ses idées sorties et
loisirs
[Applaudissements]
oh
cette semaine nous allons parler des
jeux de société une nouvelle boutique a
ouvert ses portes à montigny le
bretonneux
on avait d'ailleurs reçu il ya quelques
mois le gérant qui nous parlait du
lancement de sa cagnotte en ligne le
projet a donc abouti et le magasin des
rires et des jeux est ouvert depuis
samedi 22 mai bérengère bordoy et
justine brasier ils sont allés faire un
tour ce qui joue au carcassonne ou
encore catane ce sont les jeux de
société du moment en plein essor
l'attrait pour ces jeux a été accélérée
par les confinements alors c'est vrai
que les jeux de société avait tendance à
revenir de plus en plus avec de plus en
plus de force les gens commencent à
découvrir qu'ils avaient des jeux de
société modernes mais je pense que le
confinement à créer une accélération en
fait de la chose avec ses 1500
références en jeu de tout type kevin
armand god le gérant ne veut pas
simplement être un lieu de vente
il compte organiser dès que possible des
soirées jeux on aura des soirées à thème
donc qu'ils vont être développées autour
star fois de mécanique de jeu parfois
autour des nouveautés parfois aussi au
travers de jeux comme les jeux de rôle
dont de l'initiation jeux de rôle ou
alors faire de l'initiation à la
peinture sur figurines
l'occasion également pour les joueurs de
faire de nouvelles rencontres
c'est parfois pouvoir rencontrer des
gens qui ont cette même passion ça peut
être sympathique on peut parfois
rencontrer les gens qui sont à deux rues
de chez nous mais qu'on ne connaissait
pas et là ce sera l'occasion justement
des rencontres et un cross fading avait
été lancée avant l'ouverture un succès
puisque le montant avait été largement
dépassé cet habitant de maurepas ils y
avaient participé
le crowdfunding a bien marché donc ça
veut dire que les gens avaient envie en
soi qu'une boutique de genre ouvre ici
les clients sont au rendez vous depuis
une semaine et demie ils attendaient
l'ouverture de cette nouvelle boutique
avec impatience je pense qu'une grosse
communauté de joueurs de tous types ans
ça peut être des familles au plus pointu
et c'est vrai que à proximité directe
sur une communauté de l'agglo comme
saint-quentin plus la taille de la
communauté c'est un vraiment quoi de
beau jour sont donc à venir pour les
joueurs des environs qui pourront très
prochainement se réunir et jouer au tour
de table de la boutique la ferme de
viltain à jouy en josas accueillera du 4
au 6 juin prochain l'association pari
fermier 70 producteurs fermiers
proposeront leurs produits
cette vente en circuits courts permettra
aux visiteurs de rencontrer aussi c'est
d'agriculteurs producteurs tour du
programme dans l'interview express avec
bruno pelletier le président de
l'association
[Musique]
c'est une association du jour rien
petite trentaine d'années et qui a pour
but de valoriser ses produits agricoles
au niveau national nos objectifs c'est à
la fois de ramener une partie de notre
clientèle sur l'exploitation
mais c'est aussi et avant tout pour que
l'on puisse bon dos innoprod une
revanche directe alors il ya en général
il ya on va dire une petite quinzaine de
producteurs de vin un des gentils et
vend de la viande
donc je parlais du vison alors mais il
ya aussi la viande d'autruche et puis
enfin vous avez au lait fromage partis
sont représentés soit en format grosbill
schéma h
et puis vous avez vous eu peur des
niayes à dire via un panel de
producteurs il ya un rude et l'effort
d'épargné
en fait tout ce qu'on trouve dans la
consommation courante et mise à
disposition de la clientèle touchée
je lui ferai proposer des balades à
poney pour les enfants ça c'est
important parce que là parce que ça ça
ça donne une légitimité mais aussi à la
structure la possibilité de visiter la
perle rare le musée départemental
maurice denis à saint germain en laye
ouvre gratuitement les portes de son
jardin pendant trois week-ends de
l'événement juin au jardin proposera aux
visiteurs des animations thématiques
pierre marie vautier bonsoir vous êtes
chargée de médiation culturelle au musée
depuis la fermeture du musée pour
rénovation en 2018 c'est la première
fois que vous ouvrez le jardin aux
visiteurs alors exactement il est du
coup c'est également une ouverture en
semaine on est ouvert du mercredi au
dimanche des cours du mercredi au
vendredi ans ferme à 17 heures et le
week-end on sera ouvert de 10h à 18h
et comme vous le soulignez sais c'est la
première fois qu'on les ouvre depuis
juillet une suite et alors quel est le
but de l'événement jean jardin alors
c'est vraiment de faire que les
habitants de saint germain en laye et
des environs se réapproprient ce jardin
qu'ils ont en partie oublié c'est un
jardin a ses exceptions à ces exceptions
neil alors il est sur une pente boisé en
contrebas d'une terrasse du xviie siècle
il ya un jardin qui a hérité son tracé
du 19e siècle à une époque où la
bâtiment du musée actuel était occupée
par une compagnie jésuites des coûts des
religieux qui organisait des retraites
spirituelles et ce jardin il a été
dessiné pour inviter à la méditation
pour ou et du coup c'est c'est le tracé
qu'on a encore aujourd'hui est ce qu'on
a voulu offrir là c'est vraiment de
permettre aux habitants de parcourir ce
jardin alors on va parler du week end un
prochain le samedi 5 et dimanche 6 juin
quels seront les animations proposées
alors le 5 6 et 6 juin on s'est focalisé
sur le thème rendez vous aux jardins
du coup il y aura de nombreux ateliers
de croquis sûr sûr sûr la nature
il y aura des jeux de société pour la
famille il y aura un stand avec
l'association biodiversité 70 des 18 qui
vous donnera des conseils sur comment
avoir un jardin éco-responsable et de
nombreuses autres peu petites activités
le dimanche après midi vous aurez une
possibilité de restauration sur place
avec la petite pâtisserie de l'ennemi
voilà et de nombreuses autres petites
surprises
j'ai vu qu'il y aura un atelier et
paysagisme qui aura lieu dimanche 6 juin
concrètement qu'est ce qu'on pourra
faire lors des terres lors de cet
atelier
alors c'est un atelier de dessin
essentiellement qui qui explora
plusieurs notions de composition et de
perspectives et de coucou coucou et de
couleurs qui peuvent vous aider à
aménager un jardin voilà c'est proposé
par les plasticiens du musée et est-ce
qu'il y aura des ateliers adaptés pour
les enfants
oui alors c'est vraiment une offre qui
est famille
les familles de saint germain en laye
sont vraiment notre public cible même si
on s'adresse également aux azad aux
adultes
donc c'est vraiment tout âge est
spécialement adaptée aux familles et qui
animeront du coup ces ateliers
ce qui aurait alors que pour une bonne
partie ce seront les équipes du musée
mais nous avons également de nombreux
partenariats alors sur ce oui oui oui
oui quel là nous aurons la micro folie
de saint germain en laye qui anticipera
nous nous avons l'association bio
diversité 78 et la petite pâtisserie de
lydie alors ce premier week end je pense
que je n'oublie personne à mes amis en
tout cas le programme détaillé est à
retrouver sur notre site
il ya un certain nombre d activités qui
sont sur réservation
c'est entre autres liée au co lead alors
voilà si vous souhaitez venir c'est très
important de s'inscrire sur notre site
musée tirer maurice de fr et bien fait
noté mais ce que d'autres événements
seront peut-être prévu dans le jardin du
musée maurice denis
alors comme je vous le disais ce
week-end du 5 6 juin est centrée sur les
jardins mais le week-end suivant le 12
13 juin sera centré sur le bien-être
avec par exemple des séances de yoga le
19 juin on aura un concert de ilias
driss un jeune artiste soutenu par la
clé et enfin le 20 juin qui sera un peu
notre point d'orgue ce sera une grande
journée de reconstituer de
reconstitution historique avec un grand
pique nique qui sera animé par la
compagnie de l'histoire et des arts et
on vous invite à une kermesse en 1896
journée costumés avec jeux d'époque et
un concours de la plus belle note de
pitch très bien et bah c'est noté on
prend notre ticket merci beaucoup
pierre marie vautier d'avoir été notre
invité mais on souhaite une très bonne
soirée c'est avec plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et pour finir cette page loisirs je vous
propose une idée de sortie pour ce week
end un concert classique est organisé
samedi 5 juin à 19h30 à la salle des
fêtes de marly le roi dans le cadre des
fantaisies musicales l' orchestre de
l'alliance viendra jouer en compagnie de
la soprano marie perbos victoires de la
musique 2020 dans la catégorie
révélation artiste lyrique
le concert gratuit dure une heure
inscription obligatoire auprès du
service culturel de la ville et
l'émission continue avec eléonore pour
parler de l'actualité
[Applaudissements]
oh
pour refermer cette émission comme
chaque semaine votre rendez-vous en
partenariat avec les surligneurs ce
collectif qui décrypte les déclarations
des personnalités publiques et
politiques
on écoute vincent couronne docteur en
droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin et fondateur des surligneurs
supprimer les aides régionales aux
délinquants multirécidivistes laurent
wauquiez n'est pas le premier à évoquer
cette possibilité mais candidat à sa
réélection à la tête de la région
auvergne rhône-alpes
il est assurément le plus visible en ce
moment premier problème certaines scènes
régionales sont rendues obligatoires par
la loi
la région ne peut donc pas décider de ne
pas la verser c'est le cas par exemple
des aides à la formation professionnelle
d'autres aides sont facultatives comme
par exemple la gratuité des manuels
scolaires mais la plupart des régions
sinon tout un an malgré tout pris en
charge les manuels des lycéens
peut-on priver de cette aide d'un élève
délinquants le problème c'est qu'ici il
ne serait pas cohérent d'exclure un
élève délinquants de la gratuité des
manuels scolaires car l'objectif de
cette gratuité est bien c'est de lutter
contre les exclusions sociales en
favorisant l'apprentissage on en a la
preuve le maire de béziers avait voulu à
l'époque subordonner les aides de la
ville aux familles à l'attitude
citoyenne de leurs enfants
la justice a condamné cette décision au
motif que ces n inquiétait des aides de
secours ont pour objet de secourir les
personnes en détresse et non pas de
rapports sinon aucun rapport avec
l'attitude citoyenne de la personne mais
ce n'est pas tout comment un président
de région peut-il savoir qu'un jeune et
délinquants et en plus multi récidiviste
actuellement la région n'a pas accès aux
casiers des bénéficiaires des aides
régionales il faudrait donc modifier la
loi
et puis enfin les régions n'ont pas de
compétences en matière de répression
pénale tout cela ne veut pas dire qu'il
faudrait refermer le débat lancé par
laurent wauquiez non cela veut
simplement dire que ce débat il ne doit
pas avoir lieu à l'échelle régionale
mais nationale
c'est la fin de votre 7,8 week end on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine merci de
l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite un très
bon week end et une très belle soirée
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]